okay let me emphasize something to you
first I'll give it to you in the form
problem okay HSC markers we sit in a
room there's on a few dozen of us okay
and we have these thousands and
thousands of manuscripts right and
hundreds and hundreds of students each
and we have to mark these things now
when you do that what you see so many
students going past you you start to see
the same kinds of problems again and
again and you realize what people are
good at and what they're not so good at
now this is a big problem that's been
identified by HSC markers again and
again okay particularly in that a lot of
the emphasis in maths is on getting an
answer right I can know that I can do
maths because I can get it right or I
can get it wrong okay and if you can get
right you're good at maths if you get it
wrong all the time
you're bad at maths okay but the picture
is more complicated that and in high
school we fortunately get the time to
explore an idea there's not just right
and wrong
there's also why is that so why did you
go through those steps okay now it's the
reason why working setting out some
vitally important okay now let me give
you an example I'll take um you can
follow water I'll take an example from
the exercise I just showed you the kinds
of questions you got would be something
like this solve this okay now all right
I won't make you do it but I'm just
curious how many of you reckon you could
do that anyone yeah okay so let's give
it a go shall we
what would be the very first thing that
should do I need to put some brackets in
right I need to factorize yeah so you
think to yourself a new paradigm is that
adds to five and a paradigm is that
multiplies to six and those two numbers
are 2 & 3 2 & 3 2 plus 3 will give you 5
& 2 times 3 will give you 6 right so you
take those two numbers you do this
okay right so I factorized right now you
look at that you look mmm okay now what
do I do now there's a few different ways
you could approach it for what I would
do is I would say I know what this looks
like now this thing over here okay it's
going to intersect at negative 2 and
negative 3 right and it has a shape that
looks something like this roughly
okay so ever know the shape school
starts in the paper it's a parabola
right so then you then you look at
yourself and you're like okay I want
this to be great in Europe I want it to
be all of these parts that aren't bomb
see that that's greater than 0 they're
both ok so therefore I want X is less
than menu 3 or X is greater than
negative 2 and that's it I'm her in the
post okay now whether you understood
that or not here's my point okay but
what here the setting out these pieces
here this this and this if I'm an HSE
markup right I'm looking for these
things this question three marks okay if
all I see is this which by the way is
exactly Breyer okay out of three I'll
give that one okay because it's just the
answer it's just the answer if that's
there and there's none of this other
stuff there
you haven't demonstrated understanding
does this make sense so the way you
demonstrate understand is by putting
this stuff down right when you look at
this even if I wasn't you to explain to
you can sort of see what's going on
you're like ah it gives you some insight
into what's going on in their brain okay
but if all you saw was this
you like well the answers right okay
you'll have the answers sitting in front
of you you like tick but how'd they get
that did they just guess did they just
read it off the place and mix them and
copy it down
how much understand is that demonstrate
it's not very much okay
so therefore when you're doing your
exercises right don't don't do your
answers like this I know it takes up a
lot of space and you're like I want it
all to be nice and beat and so on but
it's no use to you if you practice in a
way that's not useful like this you want
to include all that working out stuff
right that's how you should do your
exercises that's a tip for you from the
HSC market